im Dorf Pavlo Maja Nicka sind wir mit
dem Getreidebauern war dem Schere mit
verabredet der russische Angriffskrieg
verlangt dem viel ab erst am 18 Juli
starb sein Sohn eine Mine platziert am
Wegesrand tötete ihn und dann droht dem
Familienbetrieb auch noch das
wirtschaftliche Aus letztes Jahr waren
war Diems Felder Schauplatz heftiger
Kämpfe dieses Jahr wurde sein Ackerland
nach der Sprengung des kachowka
Staudamms von den Fluten des niepro
Flusses erfasst zwei Ernteausfälle in
Folge und jetzt beendete Russland noch
das Getreide Abkommen
ist unsere
geschäftsgrundlagepreis in der Ukraine
weiter sinken so dass es für uns
Landwirte fast ein Verlustgeschäft wird
zuvor waren die Preise schon niedrig
jetzt werden sie noch stärker fallen
wo ist
sein Land hat ihn und seine zehn
köpfeige Familie immer gut ernährt zehn
Arbeiter beschäftigte er vor dem Krieg
die Löhne für zwei kann er jetzt noch
bezahlen war dem versucht das Beste aus
alledem zu machen hier soll eine kleine
Bäckerei entstehen ein Teil seines
Getreides will er künftig direkt zu Brot
machen und in der Ukraine verkaufen so
wäre er nicht mehr auf Export angewiesen
sie haben bereits zwei professionelle
Backofen bestellt sie werden demnächst
geliefert auch einen teigneter hier
kommen Regale hin das mit den
Abzugshauben müssen wir noch planen
steht wie viele ukrainische Landwirte
wirtschaftlich mit dem Rücken zur Wand
die Abhängigkeit vom Getreide Export und
damit von Russlands Willkür ist sein
größtes Problem sein Betrieb wird nur
Fortbestehen wenn er ihn auf mehrere
Standbeine stellt und wenn Vadim nicht
aufgibt
es gibt Momente da spüre ich die
Zerbrechlichkeit
dass ich einmal tief durchatmen muss
in diesen Zeiten erlebe ich
Schicksalsschläge so wie andere Menschen
hier auch
dieses Jahr ist wirklich eine große
Herausforderung für mich
aber wir müssen reden wir müssen leben
sein Land liegt an einem seitenfluss des
nipro von dort kam die Flutwelle die so
vieles Weg ist im Süden nach der
Staudamm Sprengung wird der einst
mächtige Strom wie trocken gelegt
aber im Norden führt der Tepro noch die
Wassermassen die ihn bis heute zur
Lebensader der Ukraine machen wir
begleiten ein paar drillien wohnt der
ukrainischen Armee bei Kiew ihre Aufgabe
ist der Schutz von Infrastruktur gegen
russische Angriffe für den Offizier ist
der Knie als ein Fluss er ist Heimat
ich liebe ihn sehr ich fühle mich im
Moment genau am richtigen Platz auch
weil der niepro-fluss die ganze Ukraine
verbindet von Norden bis zum Süden er
fließt durch mein ganzes Mutterland
Offizier Anton kommt aus Mario Paul vor
dem Krieg durchkreuzte er als Kapitän
eines Frachtschiffes nahezu alle
Weltmeere jetzt ist seine Aufgabe den
Schiffsverkehr auf dem Knie Brot zu
unterbinden seit Kriegsbeginn ist der
größte Fluss Europas nahezu durchgängig
militärisches Sperrgebiet auch bei Kiew
fürchtet man russische Anschläge
insbesondere auf Brücken
[Musik]
jedes Boot wird kontrolliert selbst wenn
es nur in Ufer Nähe treibt und der
Bootsführer sich als Offizier der
ukrainischen Armee herausstellt
diese Angelegenheit darf nicht privater
Natur sein vielleicht wurde dieses Boot
getestet das entzieht sich meiner
Kenntnis und es zu bewerten liegt nicht
in meiner Kompetenz meine Vorgesetzten
bestätigen dass er dazu befugt ist das
genügt der Fall ist also geklärt die
Schicht heute verläuft so ruhig wie die
Wasserlinie des kniebros
zurück im Dorf Pablo miamifka im Süden
welche wuchtwasser hat zeigt uns Bauer
war dem an seinem Haus hier lebten sie
noch im Mai mit ihren Kindern die Flut
machte ihr Haus zur Ruine
mein Mann musste mit dem Schlauchboot
zum Haus fahren
alles war überflutet
und wir wussten nicht wie unser Leben
weitergehen soll
das Wasser stand Meter hoch und das
dauerte fast zwei Wochen bis es aus
ihrem Haus abgeflossen war zurück
blieben Dreck und vollgesogene Wände
schon lange
hier sollte man gar nicht mehr
herumlaufen ihr seht das ist alles
zerstört
wir werden alles mit den Baggern
abreißen
nur wenige Meter entfernt haben Sie
bereits den Rohbau für ihr neues Haus
errichtet mit der Hilfe von Freunden
aber auch mit dem Wissen dass ihr
Familienleben dort nie mehr so sein wird
wie es einmal war ihre verloren aber wir
haben weitergemacht
jetzt haben wir unser Kind verloren
wir müssen leben
wir müssen wieder aufbauen wir müssen
Pflanzen wir müssen unsere Enkel
aufziehen wir müssen weiterleben ihrem
Mann helfe es Aufgaben zu haben sagt
Ludmilla und der Glaube an Gott dieser
muss unerschütterlich sein so wie ihre
Hoffnung noch vor Weihnachten wollen sie
in ihr neues Haus einziehen